c'est tout le monde bien délicat que
celui de la copropriété
là je le dirai certes est une mafia
dirait d'autres mais les choses changent
raymond serait le bonjour bonjour
monsieur viol tombe bonjour les
auditeurs et auditrices et aussi l'écho
bobigny terre le matin le président de
l'association de défense des droits des
copropriétaires qui doit s'ancrer
devrait faire très simple pour commencer
monsieur sorel il y as combien de
copropriété en martinique un curieuse
que nous ne pouvons pas encore défini
même pour le nombre de syndics
professionnels ne pouvons pas avoir des
renseignements nous allons les avons
cherché auprès de la préfecture
nous savons qui est un mélange agences
immobilières et syndic en même temps
alors nous ne pouvons pas répondre à
cette question
pourtant les législations qui tenteront
oui la législation est en cours mais
vous savez on est mille ans les longs et
très loin des réalités devrait le savoir
quand même ce chiffre ou et non mais
nous finirons pas les avoir parce que
nous sommes curieux et ça ajoute quand
même à cette notion de flou autour de
tout ce qui concerne les copropriétés
les syndics
oui mais une autre bulle halles pour la
vocation de la dde la dcn et d'aider les
copropriétaires si je pus mexique est
ainsi c'est une école de formation pour
comprendre que jeune école de formation
vous savoir ce que possède un règlement
de copropriété
comment fonctionne une copropriété le
devoir du kobo billets ter ses droits et
ses obligations
cela est toujours très très très
difficile il nous faut énormément de
temps pour régler le moindre petit
incident alors on va commencer par les
copropriétaires quelles sont les
obligations lorsque nous sommes dans un
espace partagé par plusieurs
propriétaires
il s'agit quand même de gier et d'un
espace commun c'est facile c'est une
question d'éducation
et je reviens encore sur un mot
formation de respect surtout de respect
mutuel
à savoir qu'il y à un règlement de
copropriété qui est mise à la
disposition des copropriétaires
règlements qu'ils ne voient même pas
nous constatons qu'après 10 ans qu'il y
a des co propriétaires qui ne savent pas
qu'ils possèdent un règlement notre
mobilité pourrait alors devoir à leurs
obligations notamment s'acquitter des
charges pas seulement ça qui
téléchargent il y a les charges c'est
très important parce que chaque mois et
nous les l'ailé je ne dirais même pas
les bénévoles parce que les syndics
bénévoles parce que ces mots là va
disparaître du langage des copropriétés
nous serons des des pas des bénévoles
mais des non professionnels nous voulons
nous voulons que le commerce fonctionne
que les sociétés qui interviennent pour
nous chez nous soient payés à date pour
faire fonctionner le commerce est que
chaque personne rentrer dans ses fonds
en temps utile on va préciser les choses
répond sorel le conseil syndical ce sont
ces l'instant ce qui représente
l'ensemble des copropriétaires et qui
s'adresse ensuite syndic pour mais que
les choses autour de bié au sein de
lieux géographiques bien précis goisses
faiblesse dans l'éco mobilité parce que
de plus en plus nous trouvons des gens
qui disent ah je n'ai pas le temps il y
a un ego et zune et gratitude qui se
développent de difficultés
professionnelles
oui à des difficultés professionnelles
il ya là la vie familiale et tout mais
on peut en conseil syndical est libre de
fonctionner est très très bien en se
voyant une fois par mois bien près
puisque quand il y aller le conseil
syndical
c'est le moyeu le pignon central de la
kobo bill était vrai tout passe par lui
parce que sans lui le syndic ne peut
rien faire c'est lui c'est le
copropriétaire et le conseil syndical
qui connaissent la kobo puis le conseil
syndical représente l'ensemble des
copropriétaires et qui donne mission à
1,6
dick le csa va de notre thé de l'espace
vert de l'ampoulé à changer de l'antenne
collective ou la réception de la tnt par
exemple et plein d'autres choses encore
le service est un missionnaire ya le
conseil syndical il peu salée pas de
l'importance et de la disponibilité des
gens ayant un conseil syndical qui gère
qui est là qui voit mais qui doit avoir
constamment l'oeil sur la vie de la
copropriété le fonctionnement du syndic
parce qu'il a le devoir de rendre aux
copropriétaires et de cerrone au cabinet
du scénic pouces voire vérifier les
côtes en temps utile le fonctionnement
et suivent que toutes les décisions
d'assemblées générales soient respectés
pourquoi décès dit qu autant mauvaise
réputation
je ne sais pas j'ai dit au pâti de
mauvaises réputations le la faute
la faute vient de conseil syndical qui
très souvent ne fait pas son travail et
laisse libre collibri chien au celtic de
manoeuvrer ce qui n'est pas normal
les rivaux champ de manoeuvre est libre
au chaud surtout de facturer et on se
retrouve avec des écarts pas possible
situation délicate non nous n'avons pas
encore un mot toutes ses preuves
nous finirons parce que nous entrons
nous avons chez nous nous sommes comme
sont bien organisés nous avons des gens
nous avons une personne qui peut éduquer
les copropriétaires les conseils
syndicaux sur la lecture des annexes
voir comment les écritures sont passés
et voir si les décisions des travaux
comme exemple budgétisé en assemblées
générales sont faites sont réalisés nous
constatons que
déjà il ya un an qu'on fonctionne avec
certains syndics traque la bien le
courant passe mais il y en a d'autres
qui ne veulent pas reconnaître encore
notre présence mais c'est à nous de
faire un travail en convoi qui est-ce
qui voudraient de mauvaises et ce sont
ces syndics coûté mais a pas de raison
que alourdit les déranger mais ce sont
maintenant des devoirs au concert dit qu
on ne fait rien sur certain nombre de
choses il y à mouvement partout est
scellée dans les copropriétés chez les
cobras italia mouvant il faut que les
copropriétaires se mettre au diapason
je n'ai bien au diapason doit suivre
l'évolution la maintenance de leur
copropriété il s'agit de la gestion de
leur propre bien annoncer il faut qu' il
faut qu'ils se disent qu'on va oublier
terrain qu'il a acheté un bien et qu'il
doit à tous les coups constamment
veiller à sa survie à sa sauvegarde
eh oui c'est comme en football un c'est
un jeu collectif parce que lorsqu'un ne
fait pas ce qu'il doit faire et bien
tous les autres en bâtissant que le
bateau coule et est ce que est ce que
c'est facile de changer de syndic
si je suis pas satisfait si nous
copropriétaires ne sommes pas satisfaits
de sa dit qu'est ce que nous pouvons le
change estat tous très facilement le
conseil syndical à leur droite pouvoir
changer de syndic
il y a le la concurrence qu'ils entrent
en jeu maintenant depuis trois ans la
loi allure impose une concurrence à tous
les niveaux sur la présentation des
devis sur la présentation de deux
contrats de syndics parce que les
contrats sont uniformes maintenant nous
constatons quand même qui a des
déviances des fois parce que il faut que
le conseil syndical soit en mesure de
servir signés sont trop près de nous qui
sommes disponibles pour le conseiller
l'orienter vers sur les tous les
contrats de syndic
est ce qu'il y a une liste une négative
liste de syndicats qui il vaut mieux ne
pas s'adresser
on va dire aux auditeurs que vous
souriez enfin nous avons eu ces temps
derniers a sauvé quatre ou cinq
copropriété
qui était qui partent il est vraiment à
la je suis pas qu'ici à la rouille nous
avons eu le temps de les sauver faire
une mise en garde les préparer et aller
vers l'autre à 5 2 3 indique avec qui
nous collaborons très bien est ce que
nous est ce que disent actuellement sont
possibles nous sommes encore une petite
creusement sont possibles monsieur sur
elle nous sommes encore une petite ou 9
ans papa norris nous exposer à trop de
désagréments à tous les soirs et tous
ceux qui les assistent nous avons nous
savons qu'il y avait ne pouvait alors
est-ce que les co propriétaires
mécontents de syndicats peuvent tout
simplement se dire nous allons nous
prendre en charge et devenir notre
propre syndic est ce que c'est possible
oui cela est possible se lève aussi
d'avoir beaucoup supplications tout
simplement de 2,2 puis de doper notre
existence nous encourageons les gens
surtout les petites copropriétés de
moins de 20 lots 15 euros nous les
encourageons à s'organiser pour qu'ils
aient un syndic non professionnels c'est
possible c'est une chose qui est très
possible ça prend du temps bien sûr ça
demande beaucoup beaucoup de
clairvoyance et question d'appeler
d'implication d'implication parce que
vous savez vous leur camp vous présenter
un budget et vous n'avez que autour de
1500 euros 2000 e au de sauvegarde en
cas d'imprévu faut savoir faut savoir
était responsable est ce que tout les
tous les copropriétaires de bartoli
connaissent votre association
non pas encore parce que nous nous
mettons d'abord à la disposition des
jeunes les ans et non non non les
enseignants et nous leur disons après un
certain temps si vous êtes d'accord
si vous êtes content lorsque nous vous
apportons vous adhérez parce que une
copropriété à une adhésion de 150 euros
l'an quelle que soit son importance et
un particulier à une adhésion de 40
euros est-ce que des syndics ont déjà
porté plainte contre vous jusqu'à preuve
du contraire non mais nos manoeuvres
vont avec énormément de précautions et
nous prenons beaucoup beaucoup de
records merci d'avoir su se mettre avec
nourri mon sort elle rappelle que vous
êtes le président de l'association de
défense des droits des copropriétaires
de martinique merci bonjour c'est à moi
de vous remercier